un chant fort interview psy je vous êtes
mito non pour répondre à l'envers non
pour répondre à l'endroit dit exactement
la vérité excuse est mégalo par moments
certainement oui il est important de
temps en temps sinon on tente rien quoi
jeu qu il faut ce qu'il faut se donner
un peu début des choses même un peu
improbable
l'ajout des paranos par périodes oui
aussi fait vous plaît ça ludivine les
mecs qui doute qui sont un peu fragiles
comme ça où quoi faire et les maîtres
qui croit dur comme fer en ce qu'ils
sont et en ce qu'ils font pai a besoin
des deux moi j'aime bien avoir le
pouvoir de rassurer donc ça me plaît les
boucles du temps fou tu étais pas c'est
jamais normal
vous aviez déjà vous n'êtes pas trop
parent au bout ça va vous mais pesant de
problème mais quand il ya doute y a pas
doute oui donc ce lien faut pas aller
par là c'est tout le doute c'est un luxe
le doute je suis pas un artiste moi je
suis pas un être sensible et délicat
tant mieux
ces gages cela limitera le constat c'est
un tracé comme on va vendre le marron va
faire un jeu du homard tient parce que
le mari par ce soir c'est comment on
fait je suis tombé
finalement les mains comme ça faut
connaître à la fin
attention
mais bon
bien à dieu
le même temps à tester
pourquoi refusez-vous belge
il savait lui-même dr omar il a acheté
le homard insomar il le paye 50 mille
balles et les cinquante mille balles
iront à michaël blanc qui est emprisonné
à ben ali voilà merci omar
attention est ce que vous êtes maso vous
avez qu'on vous fasse map
non c'est pas ne pas avoir mal mais je
me suis aperçu que souvent je mettais en
cite des situations qui n'étaient pas
forcément à mon avantage exit trouvait
certainement un certain plaisir je vous
pose même pas la question fut pas maso
qui totalement maso avant mais je leur
en ai dans mon expression picturale à
mes temps libres à 6,6
buzek saad ont mesuré d'une manière
mesurée quoi vous êtes sûrs d'au nom
sympa passant juste après sa vie est ce
que vous êtes et que si beau et vous
balader à poil devant les fenêtres en
cloud décembre passage dont vous êtes
gros lolos ba pense moment celle qui a
été même qui n'éclairent donc elle est
très grand pour sa très élancée mais
c'est pas très gros lolos c'est vrai le
gros lot je pense qu'il ya un repas la
recharge
est ce que vous êtes trio
non papa oui c'est arrivé mais bon je
suis pas là en ce moment je suis pas
trio pas la question non j'ai bien aimé
que vous ayez compris que tous vos
questions à la con vous les garder pour
l'autre côté
gym question qui peut vous intéresser la
malaisie est ce que vous êtes trop co
meilleure comparaison freddy
malheureusement non vous êtes chamallow
alors jean mallot expliquez moi là
beaucoup oussama le foia pas y'a pas un
intermédiaire se situe la joya et lâche
encore
les best-of s'appelle ce n'est que moi
le prochain cd
champion
le faire écouter là messieurs merci